investigators say the man accused of
stabbing a police officer at a Michigan
Airport has a hatred for the United
States a Morpha tui allegedly attacked
lieutenant Jeff Neville yesterday in
Flint the officer is in satisfactory
condition the Flint Journal reports fatu
II is a dual citizen of Canada and
Tunisia the paper says he has lived in
Montreal for ten years and has three
kids the FBI is investigating the
stabbing as an act of terrorism DeMarco
Morgan is at Bishop International
Airport in Flint where the attack took
place DeMarco good morning good morning
Nora investigators believe a Morpha tui
is a lone wolf that he acted alone they
say yelled Allahu Akbar which means god
is great in Arabic during the attack him
that he used a knife with an eight-inch
blade
police searched what is thought to be
the Montreal apartment of suspect amor
for two a Wednesday afternoon a large
honey knife in class the right side of a
snag according to investigators for 2e
ambushed lieutenant Jeff Neville at
Flint Michigan's Bishop Airport and
stabbed him in the neck he exclaimed
Allah and he made a statement something
to the effect of you have killed people
in Syria Iraq and Afghanistan and we are
all going to die Flint officials say
Neville fought for two eov while another
officer and airport maintenance worker
and Airport Public Safety chief Chris
Miller gained control of the suspect
lieutenant nevels never stopped fighting
never stop fighting until I handcuffed
to this person
the FBI says 50 year-old fatuity
traveled illegally from Canada to the US
on June 16th crossing over the border
near Lake Champlain in upstate New York
according to a criminal complaint filed
Wednesday surveillance footage shows
fatu he spent about forty seven minutes
in the airport before the attack he
arrived around 8:50 2:00 a.m. with two
bags at about 9:10 he went to a
restaurant on the second floor where he
stayed for about 28 minutes the
documents allege fatu II then entered a
restroom dropped off his bags came out
and stabbed Neville less than five
seconds later we have no information to
suggest a wider plot but it's certainly
very very early in the investigation
investigators say fitori is cooperating
with Ian
investigation and they plan to search
his electronic devices he's expected to
appear before a judge
sometime next week gal alright thank you
very much DeMarco